us
yeah well first of all it's very nice to
to be there at least for one time and i
was close before but i i was never able
to qualify so
i'll just uh
enjoy it and try to to play well also in
the next uh stage all right we wish you
the best of luck and we're thank you so
much for joining us lanier and good luck
in the quarter finals
uh thank you thanks for joining uh huge
reactions there by magnus what's
happening yeah he's actually
accidentally walked into a draw this
position has repeated itself three times
not three times in a row but three times
over the course of the game and
that means a draw
magnus carson losing his winning
attempts there um just giving them all
up because he repeated the position too
many times well we just uh the said bye
to lena dominguez that means uh lena
dominguez is going to face vladislav
artemyev now in the forge finals it's
going to be these two
in the quarterfinals
oh can't get enough of each other
okay uh well
magnus was not happy at all about this
uh we are hoping to get reactions
maybe you should go through it what
happened here yeah and actually i
learned something from linear there in
that interview